being unique is far more powerful than
being the best having a good name is a
huge key to good positioning is the name
memorable is it related to the topic you
want to be known for and cover never
upload videos your subscribers didn't
subscribe for if you try and own a
position that's too broad it can't even
be established it's better to narrow the
focus of your expertise and establish a
unique position as a specialist not a
jack of all trades generalist
in this episode of the think media
podcast I want to share with you six
questions every entrepreneur and YouTube
Creator needs to answer if they want to
win on YouTube this year and this is a
part of our strategy Series where we're
having higher level conversations about
how to get views how to get subscribers
and how to be different in a crowded
YouTube landscape now recently read the
book positioning which is a classic
marketing book and I would argue it's a
must read however I read the book so you
don't have to and in this episode I'm
going to be breaking down some of my
insights from the book and then go
through the six questions that we need
to answer contextualizing it all for you
so that you can get better results on
YouTube and not just experience Channel
growth but also reach your financial
targets and make money from your channel
now here's a premise of the book which
is fascinating now this book was
actually written in the 1980s so you
might say what relevance does that have
today you'd be surprised more than ever
then there was a 20th anniversary
edition which I'm holding here in my
hands that came out in 2001 and here's
what's shocking the premise of the book
is this and I'm quoting the authors it
says in an over communicated Society
very little communication takes place
there's too many companies there's too
many products there's too much marketing
noise we could say there's too many
YouTube channels
here's what's crazy
they said this in 1980 they echoed it in
2001.
and social media and YouTube had not
even started the internet was only just
starting so this is more true today than
ever before
and what they argued was that changing
Minds is an extremely difficult task
it's easier to work with that what's
already there what does that mean it
means that when there's an over
communicated Society a lot of times what
happens is that once you have the market
share in someone's mind and they're
talking about products like once you
become a Coke drinker it's very
difficult to transition someone to
become a Pepsi Drinker if you're on the
YouTube version of the podcast let me
know is it Coke or Pepsi for you or is
it Lacroix for you let me know and it
says this we're overwhelmed with
information that our brains filter out
and therefore our brains filter out most
brands that we encounter hear this again
we are overwhelmed with information so
our brains are actually filtering out
most brands that we encounter so here's
the problem for a YouTube creator
people either number one are not even
discovering You And subscribe to the
podcast because we have lots of episodes
about you know hack the algorithm start
getting discovered but number two even
if they find your Channel here's the
real sad part you do get discovered you
do start being seen you do get some
Impressions but you you don't remain in
the mind of the viewer you do get some
shorts viewers but you didn't really
build a brand you do get some views but
nobody remembers you you do get some
exposure but you're forgotten about in
the future so what exactly is
positioning and then we'll get into
these six questions well I used to think
before I read the book and secret like
when you actually read the book you like
to learn things I used to think like oh
yeah positioning is like I'm choosing
how I describe myself or I'm choosing my
brand colors I'm choosing like you know
how am I different and that's not what
positioning is actually what positioning
is is what
already exists in the minds of the
viewer or in the consumer what position
is already there now I know we're in an
emerging market and so there's
opportunity right now but the idea of
positioning is if someone already
realizes that Tylenol is what I take for
my headaches then it's going to be hard
to create a new headache medicine you
understand that maybe there's Tylenol
there's Advil and then there's the
store-bought Brands and that's the
difference between what acetaminophen
and NSAIDs like there's two different
things but like those are the dominant
Brands and there's differences so that
once there's a position so it's like
once there's someone in someone's Minds
for your expertise like who's the go-to
person
for your channel topic who's the go-to
person now in a world of content
creators is it quite as literal in a
world of business owners is it quite as
there can only be Coke or there can only
be Pepsi the answer is no but
nevertheless we can all benefit from the
positioning conversation about thinking
where are we position and one of the
reasons I wanted to invite you into this
conversation is because we're going
through this at think media right now I
started to wonder huh where are we
positioned in the mind of people as it
pertains to learning about video where
are we positioned in the mind of other
YouTube channels in the space what about
my friend Justin Brown what about Colin
and Samir coming up in terms of Creator
advice and tips what about other people
that are talking about YouTube and so
depending on where you are in your
journey getting an understanding of
positioning is going to be huge and
that's why the subtitle is positioning
the battle for your mind because what
ends up happening is the cool thing is
once you actually get a a position in
the mind of the viewer it's almost
impossible to lose the position I do
believe that coke has been number one
will probably be number one and it's
almost going to be impossible to ever
disrupt Coke is number one in terms of
cola Brands it is also there's also
massive opportunity for there to be a
number two number three number four and
then there's opportunity for there to be
a number one through a thousand other
options especially in a world of Seth
God and weird especially in a world of
marketing Warfare and we have an episode
about that on the podcast your approach
actually has to do with what your
position is and your position takes into
consideration what are your strengths
and what are your weaknesses what are
your competitor strengths and what are
your competitors weaknesses and one of
their conclusions was that a huge key
is being unique is far more powerful
than being the best so that if you can
then look at the marketplace and this is
where a lot of people make a mistake
they don't take the time to actually go
think about well wait a minute
there's already somebody that holds this
position in people's minds and so
why am I attempting to build a YouTube
Empire on an offensive attack
against someone that is already really
dominating that space when the answer
would be to take an entirely different
approach now the cool thing about
fast forward 20 years past the second
edition of this book is that we are
living in a world where there's so many
people and there's so much diversity and
2.6 billion consumers but the principles
remain the same 2.6 billion monthly
active users on YouTube watching YouTube
that there's a ton of space for personal
finance people talking to Millennials or
Gen X or Baby Boomers and then different
background you know the way you look the
way you sound your gender all different
opportunities but by the way this is all
a positioning conversation because
rather than trying to be the cookie
cutter personal finance expert Dave
Ramsey what is your unique angle to say
I'm gonna try to beat Dave I'm not going
to try to be the best I'm going to try
to be unique I'm not gonna try to beat
Richard Robert Kiyosaki Rich Dad Poor
Dad how am I going to be unique so
here's a few more takeaways that I got
from this book that I think will be
fascinating to you before we get into
the six questions but a couple of the
strategies they recommended for
positioning was one if possible be first
now that probably applies to zero of us
because you might be like Sean there is
zero opportunity to be first right now
on YouTube depends though AI is blowing
up right now there's already a lot of
people that have rushed in to probably
capture the positioning of being first
to educating people about AI makes me
think about Nikki Saunders who has gone
deep in educating people by AI apps and
she's blowing up right now nobody was
talking about AI three months ago six
months ago and so when something new
happens in the market if you can have a
first movers advantage that's an option
but here's the key if you can't be first
then your goal is to position yourself
against the first person and the person
who got there first or the brand or the
business or the YouTube channel and this
is not for the faint of heart but this
is what you would call offensive Warfare
where
um if you can't be first you need to be
against for example 7Up positioned
itself against Coca-Cola as the uncola
and crushed it so it's like okay
Coca-Cola is number one what do I do
make another Cola no you make an uncola
and they crushed it so while leaders can
copy followers followers cannot copy
leaders
is one of the quotes and so if someone's
already dominating they already have
massive momentum you're looking for
again how do I be unique versus trying
to be the best finding that unique angle
and positioning yourself against you
could consider positioning yourself
against the product the politician what
is the way to stand out in politics is
to actually be positioned against as the
alternative to one of the ways that
stood out to me was there was all these
advertisements for mud water which is an
alternative a to coffee so coffee has a
positioning in in the market obviously
there's different brands but mud water
was like healthy non-coffee for people
who don't want to have Jitters and the
caffeine and all this stuff then I saw
ads that mud water probably captured
this weird mushroom
powdery
matcha cocoa powder whatever I bought
some it it actually was like the first
of this particular product in my mind
and I was like okay and I bought some
and then I started getting Facebook ads
and they mentioned mud water and they
were like we are better than mud water
we actually have like living ingredients
and so their Market positioning was
being against mud water of a niche
within a niche category
so just a couple takeaways right you
know I hope you enjoy the conversation
be first if you can't be first position
yourself against so how can you be the
alternative to a market leader but then
the other opportunity here is to
reposition the the competition so in in
order to move your product to a new
position you move all products and you
reframe them that's what this other
company clearly not very sticky because
I don't remember their name against mud
water did Tylenol had a slogan for
people who cannot take aspirin so
because I think aspirin and Tylenol
right they're two different things in
terms of the actual drug itself like the
goal wasn't to beat aspirin the goal was
to be for people who couldn't do the
other thing your goal is to actually
reposition the competitor now this isn't
for everybody but for some think media
podcast listeners this could be the key
to your breakthrough if you have the
courage and the confidence and the
Integrity as well to say man there's a
particular YouTube channel that's being
really bold with a particular world view
a particular style of content a
particular content they're creating I'm
against that you know I'm gonna actually
go against that and and I'm gonna
reposition the competition this is what
they actually are when it comes to these
macro marketing positioning strategies
Sometimes some of the best examples of
this I mean just think about how we
could apply this to our YouTube branding
and positioning is watching politics uh
politicians duke it out looking at their
campaign pain slogans looking at how
they position
what the previous presidency did versus
uh what they're gonna do different and
so you can think about some of the
things we could do from that all right
here's another takeaway ranking your
competitors people do have a mental
ladder so for example in car rentals it
was like Hertz was number one Avis was
number two national was number three and
so then you start thinking about okay
who like this all I know my area pretty
well who who do I listen to to learn
YouTube who's number one who's number
two who's number three if you're on the
YouTube video I'm curious like is there
anybody else you listen to as it
pertains to getting YouTube advice and
then let's say you're listening to this
you're like I still want to go into that
man you got to find a slice you got to
find that if you're not number one
number two number three or those areas
are kind of Locked Up by the way
YouTube's a little bit different than
this book and I think that it's always
fair game and that for anybody who maybe
gets complacent or they get tired or
they don't continue to outwork out
strategize Outlast
um the competition
out learn then ultimately if you just
stick it out by all means
surpass what we're doing like it's a
that is I think an exciting opportunity
of just the marketplace and creating
content but here's the takeaways number
one have you ranked the competitors have
you identified and just kind of done
some some thought of okay who right now
are people going to to learn this who
right now are people going to listen to
being aware of who are The Muse the top
musicians that people are listening to
what can you learn from them how are you
position different who are the top
channels who are the top a lot of times
if you Endeavor to sell a book someday
you know you're probably never going to
sell a book to somebody who's never
bought a book The key is you actually
are going to sell a book to someone who
buys books
if it's Sean I buy a lot of books and I
never buy just one book so it's like
it's not actually a scarce world I have
never I don't just buy one leadership
book I buy every leadership book however
I'm sure there's lots I don't know so
it's like in my mind it's like John
Maxwell is probably the number one okay
well I could try to be John Maxwell what
do I do somebody wrote a book I think
about like leadership and life lessons
from like animals and plants uh John
ain't doing that that's a little bit is
different I am the foremost leading
expert on leadership insights from the
Plant World you know what I mean all of
a sudden
and then someone goes Ain't nobody got
that position in my mind are you
starting to see like how the opportunity
of okay how do I then identify so who's
the number one two three four who's the
Hertz Avis National
and what are their strengths and
weaknesses and should I even go up
against them or then how do I just
become the number one leadership
strategist from the lives of plants
because I'm I'm gonna start playing an
entirely different game this would be
all a part of the positioning process
which people have said it's literally
the Bible on strategy and the most
influential advertising book ever
written where are you on the product and
you might be saying Sean I'm just
starting this seems daunting it seems
over well well I mean well welcome to
the strategy locker room we're having a
higher level conversation and two like
if you're not on the ladder your
insights from the ladder help you
develop your unique strategy one other
thing they said two other things that
I'm Gonna Get You these questions the
power of the name the most important
marketing decision you can make is the
name of the product
I should do a whole episode on this this
kind of shook me to the core because I
was like dang but and this is their
opinion but it's definitely true Long
names could be bad as a mistake complex
names is a huge mistake and shortening
with initials a lot of times they say
initials is meaningless like MCI that
was they I think were eventually bought
by Verizon like and they're talking
about big companies but if you confuse
you lose like having a good name can is
a huge key to good positioning I think
there's plenty of YouTube channels that
have succeeded without that but if you
want to give yourself the greatest
Advantage again if the name is
forgettable if it's not sticky
if people don't if it doesn't come to
mind so if you want to have a position
in the mind of the prospect right then
you're ultimately thinking is the name
memorable is it related to the topic you
want to be known for in cover and then
also another mistake is line extension
what does that mean it means when you
become known for something the biggest
mistake you can do is start diluting
your brand by doing too many other
things and one of the things that you
recommend is rather than continuing to
extend line extension would be like you
know Tylenol PM Tylenol am Tylenol
midday Tylenol and or if it would be
what do we know as Tylenol is going to
help me with my headaches but if you did
like Tylenol for acid indigestion you
know I'm gonna get Tums if I've got if
I'm feeling like I ate a too spicy of a
dinner I'm gonna get Tylenol for my
headaches I'm gonna get NyQuil if I want
to sleep now Tylenol PM can do fine but
NyQuil right is going to be the brand
positioning in my mind of I've got a flu
and I'm trying to sleep DayQuil if I've
got a flu and I'm trying to get through
the day Tylenol if I've got a headache
Tums if I've got and then you speak to
like these names mean something they're
positioned in our mind but the problem
is line extension would be if Tums also
started like a a a a leisurely beverage
like I want Tums to like feel good I'm
not trying to like sip on Tums you know
drink just at the pool for fun right so
to be clearer one of the brilliant ways
of doing this was both both Lexus and
Toyota are the same company owned by the
same company but Toyota is more of the
economical great car positioning and
Lexus would be the luxury versions the
mistake would have been calling it
Toyota max line extension what's the
takeaway for us as content creators it's
saying that when you get clear on what
your brand is for what your channel is
for what your promise is this is why the
way we put it never upload videos your
subscribers didn't subscribe for and as
you get more advanced in your business
it starts being being we've been
thoughtful because remember this is
stuff I'm verbally processing with you
on the podcast that we're talking about
at think media and there was a season a
while ago when we had created all these
different products all these different
like Niche courses about all this kind
of stuff and we started realizing like
we also went in this whole social media
phase which was all fine and these days
it's why we like point you to even
sometimes other experts or people we
hang out with because we started to
realize like whoa whoa whoa we're like
line extension even before I read this
book like Okay YouTube Secrets the book
video make it Academy the course like
those are our key you know programs
let's make those the greatest ever and
let's go deeper with those as opposed to
just endlessly creating new stuff
endlessly getting further and further
away from the core promise but it's not
that you can't launch something else the
key key is that you wouldn't you don't
want to call it Toyota Max you create a
new brand you actually launch a new
product you do Tylenol and Tums and
NyQuil and so this might help you think
through the Journey of what you're
trying to build but for most of our
think media podcast listeners it
probably means you're doing too much
don't try to add too much complexity or
multiple meanings because if your
YouTube channel you're like oh I'm kind
of like a life coach that's like like
the name of your YouTube channel what do
you want to be known for what
positioning do you want to hold into the
mindset of the viewer and if they think
about you and they're confused like okay
I mean it's kind of like a tech Channel
but it's like cinematography tips but
they're also doing like these
motivational videos and it's also seems
like it's like for men's kind of red
pill commute like what are you doing you
know you know so line extension so I
think that's interesting all right let's
just land the plane with these six
questions now and again we'll link up
the book positioning I would recommend
this one
um it is pretty intense but I think
these strategic conversations are a big
key to us going to another level
so you can check that out in the show
notes and also if you want the shortcut
to all of this stuff
um you can just go to findyourtopic.com
and we have a very simple class that
will help you go from confusion to
Clarity in regards to figuring out your
channel Niche but let's dive into these
six questions and I think these will be
great triggers
for helping you develop your YouTube
strategy going forward so question
number one is what position do you own
now it's a very hard question to answer
if you have just started you probably
don't own any position if you are more
established this is a great question so
this is a question we're asking at think
media I'm like what position do we own
I'm not sure our action item is to do a
survey and if you are watching this
where you can comment I would love to
hear from you I wonder what position do
you think we own like it'd be very
helpful like let me know in the comments
like seriously I'll read every single
one because I am curious meaning like
who do you even think we are I'm
thinking about in a burgeoning industry
like the crater economy it is still the
wild west and I would say that if you
ask like the average American if you
said who's the number one YouTube expert
they would probably say Mr Beast like
that might be the only you know uh
YouTube where you'd think well that's
not his positioning he's more of an
Entertainer or they might say now if you
go to a more the niche category so then
if you went to like a marketing event
like traffic and conversion Summit in
San Diego or something or social media
marketing world then you might they
might say like a derral Eves or I might
say Tim schmoyer or Roberta Blake I
don't know so it's it's just what
position do you own interesting question
right and I think that sometimes this is
hard to process because all this is to
Bro energy or it's too competitive I
mean you could say that but it's also
just practical it's being like
self-aware and then the key with
positioning is you need to understand
where you are what position do you own
so that it then influences your strategy
in a way if you're applying your
strategy or shooting in the dark if
you're not sure where you stand on the
ladder or if you're even on the ladder
so how to get on the ladder I think
what's fascinating about it this is it's
kind of like it's not even just about
the destination one you want to get to
it's about where you're standing right
now being aware remember of your
strengths and your weaknesses the
competitive strengths and their
weaknesses and then applying your
uniqueness that's the exciting thing so
to bring a little love to the whole deal
is I don't even view our competitors as
competitors as most of them are my
friends but what I want to be aware of I
think this is the healthy way to do this
I want to be aware of okay where do we
stand where do they stand what's unique
about them what's unique about us how
can we be different and how can we
amplify our differences be who we're
going to be connect with the community
that resonates with us be okay with the
people who don't resonate with us be
okay with the people who don't like us
it's all good but number one what
position do you own and the goal is to
find out find a way into the mind of
hooking your product or service or your
concept to what's already there this is
why you might say something like we're
like Netflix
for people that want to learn YouTube
right or we'd say like our video record
Academy is like a YouTube College
so people go I don't really know what it
is well there's College where you can
learn skills well you can join our video
record Academy where you will learn
YouTube skills and you'll learn how to
build a profitable YouTube channel and
the seminar system so college is a
concept and we're anchoring I don't even
know what it is because maybe even
taking an online course is like new to
somebody or whatever so how do you how
do you get into the mind of the viewer
with your Channel or your idea or your
product or your service well what
position do you already own and the only
way to get heard is to tell the customer
what they already know quote from the
book so the only way to get hurt is to
tell the customer what they already know
therefore oftentimes when you relate
is a power strategy when you relate what
it is you want to do and maybe you have
a new idea for how you're going to
position your YouTube channel and you
say something you're like it's kind of
like
thing that people understand but for the
topic or industry that you want to do
it's like Netflix for personal
development which is outrageous because
that would probably be like full lengths
and documentaries and stuff or maybe you
could pull that off so like maybe that
is your vision but it's like I'm kind of
like or you also could say
um if you people who position actors or
music back in the day if you were like
grew up in Christian bookstores like me
and there would be like Christian music
and they would be like Petra was like
it's kind of like Metallica
man only the real ones know
um and so they would say like DC Talk
it's kind of like Dr Dre no not really
uh and so they would put that out but
it's because in the mind of people
there's something known and uh it's it's
it's kind of like this without that
these are some good things that could
help you even as you are positioning
your channel these are six questions I
think every YouTube Creator should ask
just to be taking to a whole other level
of strategy and relate what your YouTube
channel is or what problem it solves or
other people and so when they summarize
like an actor they're like if it's kind
of like the rock if the Rock and Sandra
Bullock had a baby that would be this
person I don't even know what that is if
you know if Limp Bizkit and Andrea Andre
Bocelli had a baby that would be this
band man I want to listen to that that
sounds interesting what position do you
own number two what position do you want
to own so I was like who owns the
YouTube coaching space and by the way
it's an Ubuntu space there's a lot of
different people in it or whatever
that's my question what's your question
what position do you want to own mistake
trying to position trying to own a
position that's too broad
here we go if you try and own a position
that's too broad here's what they say in
the book it can't even be established so
what a lot of people do they're like my
dream
is to be you know that like you go too
broad it's not even possible it would be
much better to just be like yeah when
someone has like acid indigestion
they go to Tums
it's kind of not exciting
but super powerful and probably like a
billion dollar business
so if you try in position that's too
broad it can't be established in the
prospect's mind and even if it could it
couldn't be defended you wouldn't last
there very long meanwhile it's better to
narrow the focus and your expertise and
establish a unique position as a
specialist not a jack of all trades
generalist play back the tape Sean okay
it's better to narrow the focus of your
expertise if you've been listening to
the think media podcast you might be
like man I kind of feel like you're
saying some of the things yeah like this
is uh the most influential advertising
book ever written success leaves Clues
friend there is power in narrowing your
focus
it's better to narrow the focus of your
expertise and establish a unique
position as a specialist not a jack of
all trades generalist
what if your YouTube channel
specialized and narrowed down and and
wasn't so scattered and wasn't all over
the place
then you have an opportunity number
three who must you outgun
what position does no one else have a
firm grip on okay so maybe you define
the latter
well and this is not it should not lead
it your
healthy assessment of the competitive
landscape allows you to honor the gifts
talents and abilities and what people
have built so you're just aware of what
else is out there so that you can
intelligently make an informed decision
to say okay here's number one number two
number three or here's probably the top
people or here's the other channels that
are doing it intelligently also thinking
about that the diversity of it whereas
some cases there's like whole pockets of
people you step into a whole other
language
like I sometimes have some of the most
encouraging moments I've had at VidCon I
had someone come up to me they go I am
like the number one this is a true story
I forget her name she's like I'm the
number one like YouTube educator in
Brazil
speaking the native language I was like
that's amazing she's like and I
basically copied everything like you say
kind of did it my own way but like I am
not reaching that demo because I don't
speak that language oh okay so what
position does no one else have a firm
grip on you start going to geography
language maybe you know somebody wants
to learn from somebody of a different
gender different demo different age
different generation right so who must
you outgun what position does no one
else have a firm grip on defining a
position is easy establishing it is hard
right this takes hard work number four
do I have enough money I love this
question I think the way we should ask
it is do I have enough patience grit
money
time
resilience how long am I willing to
commit to this because it takes money to
build share of mind but I I don't want
to give you an out listener to the think
media podcast
you I don't have any money okay
it takes
energy persistence and consistent
uploading of videos to build share of
mind if you want to become known for
something on YouTube you need to keep
uploading videos on YouTube over an
extended period of time with a
consistent brand consistent message
consistent feel consistent delivery of
value and that is how you build a
position and you build a brand money
simply means can you survive while it's
happening startups call it a burn rate
so will you eventually run out of
business will you eventually run out of
money will you eventually run out of
time will you eventually run out of
energy of course we all will but the key
is like staying power
so like if you say okay
this is really an uncontested area of
YouTube and the way I'm going to
position this great because it might not
take then that much energy or uploads
but if you also thought okay I'm really
going after something pretty massive
here it's just a matter of what
resources do I have this is a strategy
question this intelligent military
strategist would be thinking what are my
competitor strengths what are my
strengths my forces are low my bank
account is low so I'm going to use what
I have wisely and conversely if you are
making bigger moves you go okay this is
scary defining a position is easy
establishing it is hard but here's what
my clarity is this is who I think maybe
you feel like you're on the top ladder
maybe you're like I know who number one
and number two is I'm probably three
four or five and I'm trying to move up
the ladder do you have enough money
that's what the question is like do you
have enough energy or resources like
what resources do you have to
consistently apply Force the principle
of force against
establishing that position and again
it's not just a money thing because
there's no excuses we we don't tolerate
excuses at the think media podcast we
believe that there is a way it's not
about your resources it's about your
resourcefulness and so what they're
saying here though
is can you spend enough to get above the
noise level I would argue can you upload
enough videos of a sufficient quality on
a long enough time Horizon to get above
the noise level can you consistently
keep posting to YouTube over a number of
years to outlast your competition to
rise above the noise level one of the
ways you rise up the ladder is just
don't quit that's true because YouTube
hasn't precarious way of actually being
pretty challenging so those that are
built to last and patient and strategic
and thoughtful when they play the long
game not just the short game it's one
good way to establish a position because
you've been around long enough people
like oh yeah think media like you guys
have been around yeah for real it's 13
years into this thing so one of the
reasons we would have lost the position
is if I died it's kind of morbid it's
not funny but it's like that shock you
know it's like I mean if if you die if
you go out of business if you stop
posting if you stop right so so do I
have enough money let's redefine it as
Resource number five can I stick it out
determine your basic position and then
stick it out most successful companies
rarely change a winning formula this was
uh encouraging to me as soon as you
start winning man you want to start
doing more stuff and you want to switch
it up hey now that we're winning let's
switch it up no no like once a company's
got it remember when Coke switched up
their formula and people were outraged
they were like no no bring back classic
Coke and then they started calling it
Coca-Cola classic it's like if the
formula is working keep working it now
in YouTube of course you gotta up your
content game up you know reinvent
yourself but like if something's working
you double down on it and a company
should never change its basic
positioning strategy I think this is the
key too of course innovate your content
say stuff in fresh ways stay current but
like your basic positioning you should
only change your tactics the short-term
Maneuvers supporting the long-term
strategy so again this goes back to in
the past we started this program called
inner circle and a again it was about
like everything else meaning other than
YouTube it was about it was about like
everything so kind of a hard position to
install probably a bad name too probably
wasn't a very good name here's the thing
that's Fascinating People did love it
that got into it and people who trusted
us know that if we do something like
that it's going to be good so it got
like rave reviews but it didn't really
break through the noise probably a bad
name also if I wrote YouTube secrets and
if our main course is about YouTube and
the main thing we teach is about YouTube
we started realizing okay it's a much
stronger position and so then if it's
like yeah so yeah I'm I'm like the
YouTube guy but like also social media
and then also like online marketing and
then also like email marketing and then
also whoa line extension now you're
diluting your brand and so oftentimes
the company should almost never change
its basic positioning strategy only the
tactics of continuing to go deeper in
your message apply these and think about
man how does this apply to what I'm
doing my channel my content and
positioning is cumulative it's a
compound it's stacks Take the Long View
find new ways to dramatize it what does
that mean I think about Dave Ramsey is
one of the greats on this my gosh if
anyone has had the
one core message one winning formula the
baby steps yet has managed for all his
critics oh he's not saying anything
original I can't even imagine you he's
he's repeating himself a lot it's
hilarious to me the people that would
critique him because
he's got like a thousand team members
multiple personalities multiple shows
multiple he doesn't have multiple
personalities he may I mean there's
multiple different content creators on
his he's he's he's he's saying he's
dramatizing in a new ways his content
formula formula is worthy of study he
helps people though get out of debt
right in line extension weakens her
basic position he has built other brands
but he's named them other things and
there are also other YouTube channels
entree leadership is a whole nother
brand it wasn't just like smart money
for business owners he created a whole
new name and a whole new brand whatever
so you know want to land the plan on
this podcast got a few final thoughts
for you but can you stick it out have
you figured out your thing and you're
probably this is an advanced
conversation at a lot of levels this is
very helpful stuff to think about at the
beginning but I definitely know if
you're intermediate Advanced this is
probably like okay man it's got me
thinking on a different level it's got
me thinking about man The Long View
about what position do I want to own
what is my position and should I be
doubling down on it and not getting
distracted so can you stick it out and
keep going deeper once you've really
understand understood where your
positioning is can you avoid line
extension or are you ready because again
think about it if think media grows can
other people launch like I've thought
about doing like a think social media
channel and while we do post on social
from time because we really Teach video
the best tips and tools for building on
your influence with video heavy emphasis
on YouTube and I'm thinking about our
main Channel right now and I've thought
okay
yes social video across the board what
if we started something that would be
and maybe it shouldn't even be called
think you know so line extension is
where if we called maybe everything
think where the better thing would be
like start new brand and the only time
to do that is if we've got enough
resources and enough team and enough
ability do we have enough money to
support the whole new effort do I have
enough energy following these kids
around and focusing on and really good
questions because my answer right now is
like Whoa We actually should this our
theme this year is built to last we are
doing less trying to actually simplify
trying to actually focus on our figure
out what our position is focus on that
kill any line extension that is taking
any energy away there's a book called
The Pumpkin plan
how to grow a prize-winning pumpkin and
the key is the way to grow a giant
prize-winning massive pumpkin is to cut
off little pumpkins that are oh they're
so cute they're healthy on their own
right yeah but they're stealing
resources and energy from the main thing
that's what we eventually decided about
our Inner Circle program it was good it
was generating like 25 000 of recurring
Revenue a month but it was stealing
from the Big Pumpkin the main pumpkin
which was
narrowing on YouTube narrowing on video
ranking Academy narrowing the focus of
our team understanding how much energy
time resources we really had
and getting clearer on our positioning
number six
do you match your position
hmm do your ads do your clothes do they
match your position when people see you
when they see your music your editing
your audio quality your video does it
match your position you might tell me
here's what I do and here's who I am and
here's what my expertise is I this is
interesting because I get the chance to
review channels and I think that in some
niches it matters less I think for some
topics it matters less and I think
that's the key because what's what's the
position
but one of the most interesting things
that I'll see is like channels teaching
you how to be wealthy channels teaching
you about about personal finance
or church teaching about investing and
there's something about if I'm going to
trust you for financial advice how are
you dressed and I don't mean like wear a
suit and tie although that could be it I
just mean if it's like
messy room behind you
sketchy outfit Low video quality and
you're telling me how to manage wealth
and manage money it's like do you match
the position
the thought do your clothes do your ads
does it match the position you're after
and ultimately a quote from the book is
creativity by itself is worthless only
when it's subordinated to the position
of objective can it make a contribution
so sometimes we just get super creative
look at my background look at my set
look at my clothes look at the video set
up look at all this great but does it
support the position just sharing you my
takeaways from the book apply them how
you will but I think this is relevant
just being create creative for
creative's sake what they would argue is
worthless bringing your flavor your
Unique Style your unique brand all of
that stuff is is important but they're
saying it's subordinated to the
positioning objective so what's your
core promise what's your Channel about
what would the Market's perception be
what position do you want to have in the
prospect's mind and creativity submitted
to the positioning objective is valuable
but creativity in and of itself just
because my videos are cool and the
editing's quirky and like I got LED
lights in my background and yeah it's if
it's a mishmash of a bunch of different
stuff how are people going to remember
you how are you going to stand out and
so ultimately those are six questions
what position do you want to own what
position what position do you own right
now what position do you want to own
number two three who must you outgun for
do you have enough money five can you
stick it out and six do you match your
position are you aligned and if not how
can you get aligned with your position
I'm curious your takeaways and your aha
moments from this episode of course rate
and review on Apple and Spotify or
Google or wherever you listen to the
podcast but on YouTube I'd love to have
a conversation and I really want to
engage with you on this episode and I'll
read every comment I'm curious also you
know what position do you think we own
one of the things we've been doing is
doing some specific surveys on the
community tab if you're just starting
YouTube you may feel overwhelmed like
this doesn't apply to you I would argue
it does however you don't own any
position yet you're just starting so
this is going to inform maybe how you do
competitor research but if you're more
established the action item we're taking
is where we're actually going to be
doing a proper upcoming annual survey as
we've done in the past because we want
to get to know you better but I would
love to hear from you in the comments
um again like who who do you think who
do you go to for advice in business or
entrepreneurship or YouTube advice I'm
curious where do you think Sean Cannell
the brand or think media the brand is
literally that would be Priceless to me
and I would love to hear your feedback
if you've geeked out on this episode you
may love reading this book the entire
think media team is reading it just so
we can stimulate conversation as we're
thinking about it it's been valuable to
us I know that these episodes man we're
going on like 50 minutes and this is a
deeper dive strategy conversation but we
are putting all these episodes into a
playlist and I know this is different
than what we normally talk about but I
know for me it's been incredibly
valuable and the greatest content
creators and contentpreneurs and
business owners are gonna not just out
work not just out learn but they're also
going to out strategize and Outlast the
competition and so I would be doing you
a disservice if I didn't invite you in
to the fact that those who have higher
levels of strategy and strategic
thinking and hard thinking and
analytical awareness of what's happening
in the market around them and who the
competitors are not in such a way that
it leads to insecurity but in a way that
it leads to insights so that we could
better take our strategic approach to
realize man why was I even fighting so
hard against that the competition when I
could have carved out my unique
positioning crushed it and built a life
in a business that supports my family
and makes a difference I think that we
could do that on the other side of
better strategy so thanks again for
listening to this episode my name Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel and
I look forward to seeing you in a future
episode of the think media podcast